why do you believe this stock is poised
to fall we think there's a very good
chance that it's about to lose close to
half of its revenue for period that
could be two years or longer and this
would be due to device recalls okay
explain sure so we are aware we've been
made aware that these implantable
devices I'm talking about defibrillators
to talking about pacemakers yes and
likely also device called CRT these are
part of an ecosystem where there are
four parts for our intents and purposes
to this ecosystem there's the device
that's implanted in the patient there's
the physician's office programmer that
sets the settings there's the st. jude
network servers that receive data and
also push updates to the programmers as
well as to the at-home device and there
are hundreds of thousands of these at
home or home monitoring devices called
merlin at home devices that are out
there in the wild and this is really the
crux of the thesis and that is there
should be a secure communication
protocol between all of these devices
however these the communication protocol
has been compromised or it is greatly
compromised particularly by these Merlin
at home units and with hundreds of
thousands of them in the wild basically
the keys to communicate with the
implanted devices and make them do
things that they shouldn't be doing to
cause them to malfunction those keys are
out there and they're relatively low
hanging fruit for attackers to exploit
so if I understand correctly what you're
saying you found a security flaw you
found an Achilles heel yes we were made
aware of it we didn't find it ourselves
but we were approached by a group of
cyber security researchers a company
called med sac that had been doing a
study on the four largest manufacturers
of implantable cardiac devices and the
security and so what they found with the
st. Jude's devices in the ecosystem
stunned them I mean is far worse than
anything
it was doing this independently of
anything you were up to yes they were
doing this completely independently and
when they found this they they really
were faced with the decision because
ordinarily in the cyber security
industry if a firm finds a vulnerability
they'll approach the manufacturer and
they'll let them know about it and if
the manufacturer doesn't do anything
about it after a period of time then
it's considered to be fair play for the
researcher to go public with it but in
this case what they saw in this
ecosystem these devices are so poorly
protected that they felt and we agree
that this is likely gross negligence on
the part of st. Jude over many years and
so they were concerned that if they went
to st. Jude saint jude would sweep this
under the rug and they felt that it's
very important for users of these
devices for patients to know about the
risks and you know our assessment as
well as that if med sec is that for a
number of years st. jude in this realm
has been putting profits before patients
and that's why they came to us